人が入れるのは入れる時は問題だったら自分でもその数字を入れてあげると
そこでもう人が手でやらなくちゃいけないことは
この角度でこれぐらいこれぐらいですとか
ちゃんと出ますから それ分だけやってあげれば
もう自動コントロールでもう着陸も自動着陸でできるようなところまで進んで
ですから仏教の世界でも
会議すれば会があったり
会あったり 会があったり
沙弥会は種類入るまで種類あったり
もう会はもう何億ぐらいもうわかりませんだけど
いっぱいあったりとか
冊分もテキストありますから
もうそこは全部勉強してあげれば
もうやりきれないんですね
それで社会は変わるたびに我々の生き方は変えなくちゃいけないし
だからもう決まらない
それでつのスイッチで
それはもうコントロールできますよと
正語と正語 正語っていうのは言葉
サンマーラーチャン で
サンマーワーチャーということ
で どうせ人間喋るんだから
そこら辺ちょっと照準してみます
生きるっていうことを喋るってどういう大事なことなんですね
そこら辺もただ喉からどんな声も声も出すんじゃなくて
ちょっと言葉を操縦しなさいと
で ちゃんと操縦して喋る人々は立派な言葉を喋る
喋ったことで自分殺されるようなことは喋れない
人は結構殺されてる場合でも
原因は何ですか？と探しても
何か喋ったんだからでしょうに
政治家の世界でもね 国際的な問題でも
なんかどうでもいい何か一言言ってしまっちゃう
それで社会問題 国際問題が出てきたりとか
総理が辞任辞任しなくちゃいけないで
ちょっとちょっと一つ言葉言っただけのことで
と言っても だからこれ危ないんですよ
人間っていうのは喋ってないんです
とにかく みんな病気なんですよ
精神的にすごくストレス溜まっちゃう
ストレス溜まる 感情がもうもう何て言いますか
詰まっちゃう で どこかでそれを発散しなくちゃいけない
それでも口からもうなんか喋る
ただそれだけ それ聞いてるバカどもが
この人はああ言った こう言った
なんでこう言うんですか
それはいけません それはけしからんとか
そこで国際問題の個人の問題から国際問題まで
それから世界戦争まで
それを発達させる 我々のあのバカが何も言ってないんだと
あの人は精神的な病気でストレス溜まっちゃって
もう感情はもう溜まっちゃって
ただ自分の感情を発散しているだけですよと
例えば人が私に向かってあなたみたいなもう腐ってる人間は見たこともないんだとか
あんたもうとんでもない人間だとも
もう生まれてこなかったならばそれよかったんではないかとか
もう言いたい放題いっぱい言うかもしれません
だからといって私はそうなるわけじゃないでしょうに
人が私はインチキやと言っただけで
私はインチキになるわけじゃないし
人は私はあなたは泥棒ですと言っただけで
私は泥棒になるわけでもないし
人は私にあなた本当にバカもんだよと言ったんだから
私はバカになるんですかね
そうはなれませんだから
ただ見えるのは その人は何かちょっと落ち着いてないんだと
怒ってるんだと 嫉妬しているんだと
それだけでしょう で 私に人があなたはもの大バカもんだよと
インチキ野郎とか何とか言われると
私はバカもんでもインチキ者になるわけじゃなくて
その人は怒っている それだけのこと
怒ってるんだからただ声出してる
喋ってるわけじゃないんです
で 私たちもものすごく高熱を出して倒れる時ありますね
その時はもうあまりにももう熱だからいろんなこと喋るんです
それを真面目に受け取る人がいるんですか？誰もいないでしょうに
あ このすごいひどい熱だから
早く早くこの体を冷やさなくちゃいけないんだとか
誰かが氷枕持ってきたりとか
氷で体を冷やしてくれたりとか
そういうことをやってくるだけでしょうに
その時は熱出して口からいろんなことを出る
その時ももう体がコントロールを失って
脳細胞をコントロールを失って
あまりにも熱だからパンク状態になっているだけのことです
冷やしてもらえば大丈夫です
で 同じの人々はもう同じ
このそれは何と言いますか
日本語でこの喋ることは熱が出た時とかね
うな？うなごとですか？うわごと
そうそう 大体世の中の人間っていうのは喋ってるんじゃなくて
ただうわごとを言ってるだけなんです
じゃあ国会の状況いつでもありますから
見てください 誰が喋ってるんですか？誰も喋ってない
ただウワサ言ってるだけ
それを真面目に聞いたりして喧嘩すったりとか
あれは僕にとって面白いことないんですよ
だから野党側与党側とかね
むしろ立ち上がってぶんぶん殴るぐらいまで行ったんですかと
ただもうそれだけの話で喋ってるだけだから放っておけばいいのに
それ立ち上がって相手ぶん殴ったりとか
そこでもう国会からもう国会中止したりとか
いろいろなことを だから面白いんです
とにかく 楽しがってる人にとってはものすごく楽しいんです
そういうのを見てるの
どれもいいことだから
別に真剣に聞く必要はないし
世の中の人々はただ喋るのは喋りたくてしょうがないんだから
でも 喋りたくてしょうがない人々
喋る言葉には何の意味もないんです
何の意味もないんです
聞かなくてもいいんです
ただ見えるのは その人の心の中に落ち着きがない
だからこの落ち着くまで
この高ぶった感情が発散して終わるまで喋る
私たちも喋るとすぐ心にサティ入れてみてください
あ ちょっと何か溜まってるなと感じるはずなんです
溜まってるものを喋らないと
喋ってしまわないと なんかまた後でまた何か残ってるんです
そういうことで喋るんだから
そんな人の話なんかはもう聞く必要もないし
心に受け入れる必要もないし
ものすごいバカバカらしいんです
例を挙げると ちょっとしたことで
あなたにおしゃれのセンスは全くないんですねとか何か言ってみてください
誰かの女性の方にどうなるかわからないんですよ
結果としては だから 例えば自分にそう言われたとするならば
言われたと仮定すると
あなたには全然おしゃれなセンスがないんだとというと
それはその人の判断であって
その人の感情であって
その人は世の中のことを見て
あ これはいけないと おしゃれのセンスというのは
そのその個人には別々だから
この絵は綺麗だ この絵は綺麗じゃないっていうのは
その個人の勝手だから
美の世界だから だからその言ってる人がバカもんで
おしゃれのセンスがあるかないかと言える言えたもんじゃないんですよ
その個人がそれ気に入ってるならばしょうがないでしょうに
ですから 傷ついたとか
なんてことを言うんですかとか怒るのがまたかえってバカバカらしい
言ったこともバカバカらしいし
言ったってもいいんだけど
それに傷つく傷ついたというのは一番バカバカらしいんですよ
言った方がいいというのは
それでその人のおしゃれのセンス
我々に分かりますから
あなたにおしゃれのセンスは全くないんですよという人のおしゃれのセンスがいくらも理解できるでしょうに
ですから まあ言いたい人は言ってもいいんだけど
それにも乗せられて怒ったり喧嘩したりする場合は
それを乗せられた人々はもう何の意味もないんです
だからそれぐらい理解すると
この社会問題っていうのはもう 95%以上解決するんですよ
ほとんどの問題 口から
日本のことわざもありますからね
わさわいは何ですと なんとも災いの元だ
それもその通りで だから言葉さていうのは悪い言葉で喋るなというところなんですけど
我々は逆に聞くなと言いたいんです
人は喋っとるんじゃなくて
ただ私はあることはもう何か道路で足やら
あるいは階段に足をぶつけたかと
ぶつけたらものすごく痛くて
あー痛いと言うでしょうに
だから他の人はなんで痛くならなくちゃいけないんですか？私は痛いんだから
痛みの痛みの感情を自分が表現しなかった
しないとなんとなく痛みが消えないような感じがするんですよ
あれはこのサティの働きなんです
あ 痛いと言ったところで
結構痛みが消えて もう我慢できる状態に戻るんです
だからそれは法則だから
みんな本来知ってるんです
だから痛い痛い痛いと言う
言うと落ち着くんです
それだけのことで それ聞いたら
もう聞いた人も ああ やっぱり痛いでしょうと痛くなる必要はないんです
だから世の中の人は別に喋るものは自分の感情状態を表現しているだけ
それは真に受ける必要はないと
ですから 口は災いの元かもしれませんだけど
耳も同じですよ 耳は災いの元なの
聞くなと 人の話は サティ入れてくださいというと
次に出てくる問題はサティで音を聞くと人の言うことを理解できませんと
私に何回も文句あったでしょうに
質問が それで人を言うことを理解できないんだと
これでは社会で生きていられませんと
なんで聞く必要あるんですかね
人を言うこと 人を言うこと聞くんだから
いろんな問題あるんであって
社会の中でうまく生きていられなくなって
言うこと聞くんだからでしょ
ですから音でいいんです
そういうことで 私たちが言葉の上手な操縦士になる
何だかんだも喋るんじゃなくて
人々っていうのはもうバカだから聞くでしょうに
聞いて不幸になるんだから
喋ったらこっちが勝手に喋ってるんだけど
向こうを聞くんだから
もう聞いたところで 向こうには向こうの心は傷ついたり
怪我したり もう世界戦争したりするんだから
それでも明るい人はまあどうしょうもないと
だから自分が言葉をちゃんと操縦しますと
ということは その自分の自分をちゃんと操縦することはサンマーワーチャーと言うんです
称号と言うんです で きめ細かい説明はまあ要りませんだけどね
やっぱりあの嘘を言ってはいけないし
噂言ってはいけないし
きつい言葉を言ってはいけないし
無駄話は良くない それだけ
嘘を言ったら人は聞くんだから大変な目に遭うでしょうに
もし人が聞いてくれなきゃ
別に嘘を言ってもいいんです
それちゃんとアビダンマで説明してるんですよ
嘘は完璧に罪として成立するのはする条件
自分が嘘であることは知る
それで喋る 相手が聞く
聞いて騙されると そうすると嘘の罪が成立するんです
相手が全然信じてくれなかったら
嘘言ったことにならないんです
ということで 我々喋ることは人々は聞いちゃう
聞くんだから 人々に戒律守ると言ったってもね
意味がないし 自分でも守らなくちゃいけないんだから
自分が嘘言わない方が一番正しい
そうすると人を騙したことにならない
騙された人々は決して自分にいいことはしてくれない
そこで騙すということは
やっぱりものすごい危ないことで
この悟りの世界はなぜ生まれないかというと
我々は自分を騙しているんです
だから この善心性不善心性の説明で
この騙しということは僕はよく使ったと思いますけど
我々はごまかしている
自分を騙している いつでも
ですから そこはもう基本的な問題で
自分で自分を騙すことをやめた瞬間でも悟りは得られますから
それよりはレベル低いんだけど
人を騙すということは
もともと自分嘘の世界好きなんです
例えばもう名刺作るとか
もうあり得ない いろんなものを書いたりするとか
そこで本人がもう人を騙す
自分も騙してるんで 私は偉いんだと
でも偉いと思ってももう言うことはないんだから
何でも何とか何とかと書いてしまっちゃう
名刺見る人々も名刺で判断するんですね
名刺っていうのは この人の名前ぐらい名前で住所とかね
電話番号とかね それぐらいの具体的なデータを伝えるためにあればいいんですよ
でもそれ名刺は肩書きいっぱいいなければもうカッコつかないんですね
そこでその本人がインチキの世界で生きていて
嘘の世界で生きていて
それで人に言おうとしていると
それと人に嘘を言うのは
心の中は嘘の塊だからなんです
生きてないんだから生きる自信がない
そういうことで ですから嘘を言うなと
で 真実語れと 真実語ろうとすると結構静かになるんですよ
口は 嘘を言う人だといくらでも喋れますからね
嘘は でも真実っていうのはそんなにたくさんないんです
喋るものは そうすると結構静かになるんです
こっちが静かになればなるほどストレスはないってことなんです
別に喋ることはないんだから
これはこれだ これはこれだと言ってそれで終わりと
ということは 心がずっと静めているんです
ですから あまり喋らないのは大変徳だと
すごい道徳 美徳なんだね
仏教の世界では 経典読んでみると見つかるというのは
いつでも言葉少ないことをすごい美しく褒めてるんです
ほとんど喋らないことと
お釈迦様は弟子たちが集めても喋らない
誰も 単なるこのなんか沈黙行とかそんなくだらないことじゃないんです
じゃなくて みんなそれぞれ静かにもういる
ですから そういう姿 すごい美しい
みんな落ち着いていて
座っている 集めていても
それでお釈迦様にとっては
昔 1,000人  2,000人
何千人集めても説法できるんです
みんな静かだから 静かというのは口だけじゃないんだから
心も静かだから説法できますよ
ただ 私はいくら喋っても理解しないでしょうに
というのは 頭は静かじゃないんですね
頭でずっと喋っている
そういうくだらないことを喋っているのは
これ私は壊そう壊しているし
自分の文化的ないろんな概念やら固定概念
アッパイばっかしで それでうるさく喋っているんだから
こちらの言葉は入る余地が全くない
ですから ものすごくうるさいんですね
心の中というのは で 仏教の世界になったら真実しか喋りませんよと思ったら
真実はそんなにたくさんないんです
人間にとっては ですから静かになるんです
頭の中 そうすると大事な話だったら何でもざっと入ることが入ります
ということで ですから
称号はそういうふうに嘘言ってはいけないし
きつい言葉を使ってきつい言葉で自分が怒ったら
怒ったら相手を傷つこうという気持ちで喋る言葉はきつい言葉になるんですね
相手の態度をね キスすることはない
それは怒りの行動だから
それはやめた方がいいんです
あなたがすごい暗いんです
その代わりに慈しみの言葉を喋ると
そうすると心はすごくまた柔軟性が出てきて
柔らかくなって明るくなってしまう
で あのー 噂は良くないと
噂っていうのは どうせ人の平和を壊すために
調和を壊すために言ってる人の悪口なんです
それいいわけじゃないんだから
自分が嫉妬して人を仲良くしているのをもう嫌で嫌で
で そういう仲のいい人々に
この人の悪いことをこの人に言って
この人の悪いとこをこの人に言ったりと
人間には悪いところもいいところもありますから
そんなどうでもいいんです
そんなことは ですから
この それまた馬鹿馬鹿しいでしょうね
わざわざある人の悪口をまた他の人に言うと
もしその人に特別に悪いことあるならば言ってもいいんですよ
それはニュースだから
あんた知ってますか？なんとかなんとかさんはこういうこういう人だよ
それはニュースでもなんでもないんです
どんな人間にたっても
そういういいとこ悪いとこも
もうほとんどほぼ同じくあるんですよ
だから噂を言うっていうのは
もうものすごい無知な
もうおかしい行動なんです
じゃあ言ってる本人が完璧ですかと
そうじゃないでしょう
それで言われる側があんた知ってますが
Aさんはそういう人だよとこの人に言う
Bさんが聞いてるならば
じゃあBさんにはそういう悪いことのとこないんですかね
自分にもあるでしょうに
いろんな欠点はあるんだったら聞く権利はないでしょうし
そうするとそのちょっと待ってくださいと
人の悪口言っても 実は私も完璧じゃないんだと
私にもそういう そういう欠点がありますからね
それは聞く権利はないんだと
だから人間には噂を言う権利はまずない
ニュースじゃないんでしょうに
例えばあんた知ってますか？ Aさんには髪の毛がありますよと言ったらバカにされるでしょうね
Aさんはもう服着替え服着てるんだよとか
夜寝るとパジャマに着替えますよとか言ってみてください人に
バカにされるでしょ ニュースじゃないんです
あんなことは 人に言うならば
ニュースだったら言ってもいいんです
でも人間の欠点はニュースじゃないんです
あの人奥さんと喧嘩しましたよとか
会社で失敗しましたよとか
女に手をだそうとしてぶん殴られたよとかね
そんなのニュースじゃないんですよ
よく世の中にごく普通の
あることで もし人の まあここら辺から額から角でも出ているならば
それはニュースですから
もう言ってもいいんです
ですから こういう人の悪口を言うのは良くないし
ニュースでもないし もう言ってる人がこの社会の調和平和を壊そうと狙って狙ってるんです
睨んでるんです だから噂を聞くのは良くないし
言うのもよくない 噂を言う人はもう追い出せ
別に構いません だからきつい追い出し方があります
人が人の噂はまあ言うと
大体特に女性の場合はもう何も言い返しできなくて
あのもう聞くしか方法ないんですね
ああそうですか そうですかとか
まあ男の場合は何かきついことを言ったって構ない
女性はあまりこういうこと言わないでしょうし
だから噂を聞く羽目になっちゃうんですね
後で怖くなっちゃうんですよ
もしかするとその人はあの人のところに行って私のことを言うかもしれませんと
誰でもそういういいとこ悪いとこ持ってるんだからしょうがないでしょうに
だからこの人来る時も気持ち悪いんだけど
あんたもう家に来ないでくださいと言えないんですね
だから二度と来てほしくなければ
その人を褒めればいいんです
噂は持っていると素晴らしいですよと
で そういうとこまで見つかるぐらいあのあなた本当に立派にできてる人だから性格はね
やっぱり私なんかは自分ももうもっといろいろとこあるんだから
人のことは言えないんだけど
それ言えるのは素晴らしいことだと
よく性格できてるんだと
完璧だと そんなにもう微かな間違いもない
あなたと仲良くできて私は幸せだと
で 言ってあげたら二度と来ないんです
貶したわけでもないし
向こうは怒れませんし
あなたの性格は素晴らしいですよと言ったところで
どうやって怒れますか？怒れないでしょう
でも大体人は言われた言葉は二度と思い出したり
観察してませんから安全なんです
観察してたらすごく怒る可能性ありますけどね
で そういうふうな この
そういうまあ中道的な
この もうやり方なんですけども
言ってあげればもう来ても
まあ人のことはもう言わない
まあ自分がすごい大事な立場で上の立場でいるならばはっきり言えますけど
二度とそういう話は言うんだったら二度と来なくてもいいんだと
こっち来るならばそういう話はしないでくださいと頼みますけど
それは自分がちょっと上の立場でないと
それはもう同じ立場だったらやっぱり難しいし
あるいは相手がもっと上の立場だったらまた難しい
その同じ立場と自分より上の立場の場合は
こういう風に褒めてあげると
その人も人に噂言うことをやめちゃうし
自分もそのややこしい状態から逃れるし
どちらにでもいい結果なんです
友達関係は消えるかもしれませんだけど
それから罪を犯すこともなくなりますからね
ですから そういう噂話
それから無駄話なんですね
無駄話 私もすごいもう時間が終わるまでほとんど無駄話でしたけど
無駄話になるとまたうるさいんですね
いくらでも喋られますから
いくら聞いても相手には何の役にも立たない
そういうのはやめた方がいいんです
自分の感情を荒らすために喋るものはほとんど無駄話なんですね
ですから 結局人間喋ってるのはもう九十九パーセント無駄話なんです
ただ喋りたくてしょうがない
それだけ それで喋る そこでこの言葉の操縦する人がそうじゃなくて
自分の体からどんな言葉発生した方がよろしいかと
言葉にしなくてはならないことだけ言葉にする
そうすると無駄話にならない
大事な言葉になる 人に言葉でしか
通じられないもの いくらでもあるでしょうに
例えばドラマとかそういういろんなもう劇ありますね
もう歌劇とかなんとかとか
そういう場合はもう歌でドラマやるのはいいんだけど
歌で表現できないいろんなものあるでしょうね
それでいつもすごく苦労するんです
ですから まあいろいろ世の中でやっぱりあの
こういうことは言葉にしなくちゃいけないと
言葉でなきゃわからないということがある場合は言葉にする
そうすると意味のある言葉になる
で 次にあるのは正語 サンマーカンマンって
その場合は体の行動 体の行動を操縦してほしい
我々歩く時でもちゃんと自分の足を操縦しているわ
電車に乗る時でも 自転車に乗る時でも
まあ自動車に乗る時でも
ちゃんと体を操縦しているわ
それで自分身を守っているわ
ですから我々はちゃんと体のストイックな操縦士にならなくちゃいけない
それはどういうことかというと
やっぱり殺生してはいけないし
人に害を与えてはいけないし
酒やら麻薬やら取ったりして体を壊してはいけないし
それぐらいのことなんです
[背景音楽]体があるんだからって言って
あっち行って遊んだり
こっち行って遊んだりして
人生は不幸にしていけないし
それ四つ 三つぐらい パナディパータ アディナーダーナ カーメスミッチャチャーラという三つなんですね
パナディパータは殺生
アディナーダーナというのは盗むこと
カーメスミッチャチャーラというのは不邪淫
で それぐらい不邪淫といったって
もう遊ぶなと 体があるんだから遊びます
そういうのはいいわけにならない
そんなあっちこっちで遊んだりすると
もう自分が不幸になりますから
いい操縦士じゃないんですね
で 生命に害を与えて殺したりすると
自分も害を受けますから
いい操縦士にはなれないし
盗んだりするとまたもう同じこと
そういうのをやめると
それ三番目は正命 それは正しい命ではありませんね
漢字では命なんですけど
で いつでも日本ではよく間違うんですね
定義 説法すると みんな漢字を見て
あ これは正しい命やと
これは命っていうのは魂だと
だから魂は正しくと という風な
ありますよ 有名な本なんか読んでみてください
魂は清らかに正しく守らなくちゃいけないと
それは八正道ですが 全くその通り違います
命と命ですけど アージーヴァというのは生き方であって
どうやって生きていますかということなんです
それも体の操縦なので
ということは 人間は死んじゃうでしょう
何もしなきゃ 何か食べて生きていなくちゃいけない
ですから あなた何をして食べてますかということは正業なんです
いわゆる職業なんです
仕事なんですよ すごい簡単な意味なんです
どうせ人間は仕事をしなくちゃいけない
食べるために 食べるために
自分を住むために 服を着るために
病気になったら薬を買うために
家族の面倒を見てあげるためには
自分が仕事をしなくちゃいけない
何とかしなくちゃいけない
その何とかすることはちゃんと気をつけてしなさいと
それだけ 金さえ入れば何でもいいというわけじゃないんです
金さえ入れば銀行強盗でもいいということですから
そうじゃないんだから
瞬時に金が入るかもしれませんだけど
次の瞬間からはもう何もない状態だから
ですから 仕事のために悪いことをするなと
でも仕事をするなとは言ってないんです
仕事だといって悪いことをしないで行動すればいいんです
毒を作ること 毒を売ること
武器やらね そういう武器の製造
武器の売買 麻薬の製造売買というのは
そういうのは仏教の人々には禁じられています
で 動物の売買は禁じられています
動物を買ったり売ったりするなと
すごい素晴らしい意味だと思いますよ
動物も命だから 私に動物を飼って捕まる権利ないでしょうに
この猫は 20万ですよと
この犬は 15万ですよと
この牛は一千万円ですよと
ですから 我々はものすごいとんでもない罪を犯してるんですよ
生命の次元から見ると
あなたは何様ですかと
人の生命も秤で量ってみて
値段これぐらいですよと
この鶏はもう 10キロありますから
これぐらいですよと ここではこの生きている鶏売ってませんだけど
このもう香港とかね まあそこら辺
中国系あっちこっち行ってみてください
あるいはイスラム系 こういった人々がいるところなんかもう
もうまあ大体もうそういう南アジアも東南アジアの骨も皆さんはよく見ているでしょうね
鶏なんか持ってきて そのまま秤に入れてもう測って売るんです
だから 秤の上で鶏はこうやって翼を叩いたり
もうもういるんですけど
だからその権利 人間にどこにあるかというとね
で まあそれは食べるんだからといって
もうというふうな もう理解はしても
それ売れ人間またやってるんです
人間まで捕まったり 売ったり買ったりしてたんだから
それくらい恐ろしい人間もこの世の中にいたんです
人を捕まって誰かに売ると
で 一旦売られたら その人一生あの人の奴隷で仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだ
おかしいということは
例えばこの人は私があなたを買ったんだよと言っても
買われた側が奴隷ですから
関係ないでしょうに お金もらったのは売った人でしょうに
だからある人がアフリカに行って人を捕まえる
そこまで競りに出して売るでしょうし
で 買った人は私はすごい高いお金で買ったんだからといって
一生お前は私の奴隷で仕事をしなさいと
あれどういう理屈か分からないんですね
それこういうそういう連中が我々には合理的じゃないんだと
迷信だと またその上言ってくれるんだから
よくも ですから もし奴隷が自分の主人をぶん殴ったりすると
すぐその場で奴隷を殺してもいいんです
普通の常識で見る 奴隷は主人をぶん殴って怪我して逃げても正しいなのに
もし奴隷にお金を払って
昔インドにあったような感じで
お前にはこれぐらいお金あげますから
お前一生私の奴隷にならなくちゃいけないんだと言ったならば
奴隷も儲かってるんだからその分責任があるんですよ
まあそういうこともたまにアジアではあったんだけどね
まあ家族はもうお金がなくて
いろいろ大変困っていて
それで娘さんやら息子さんやら誰かのうちのうちに上げて
お金いくらかもらおうと
そのうちでその人は仕事をしながら一生生活しなくちゃいけないし
で その場合はその払ったお金
仕事でいわゆる仕事をして返せば
人は自由になるんですよ
例えば 10万円をもらったと
両親が それも一年 十年経ってでも
二十年経ってでも  10万円の分その子が仕事をしてあげれば
もう何のことなくもう自由になるんです
あるいはまた家にはまたお金が入ってきて
まあお金あげますから
私の子供返してちょうだいと言ったら
ちゃんと返してくれる
それは別にいくらでも理屈はありますよ
奴隷制度でもないんだから
ですから そういうところはもう売買というよりはね
まあ普通の人間 between の間の契約であって
ですからまあそういうのはアジアではもう結構ありました
現象で 今ももう時々あるし
で 仏教ではもっと厳密に
やっぱり生命は売ったり買ったり
売買はいけないと だからと言って家畜動物は禁じるとかそういうことでもないんです
自分がもう家畜動物をやるならば
一生懸命動物の面倒を見てあげて
その分仕事をしてもらって
お互いに幸福になればいいし
それもまた別の話で ゾウさんを捕まったならば
ゾウの面倒を見てあげて
ゾウさんにもその分仕事をしてもらうと
すごく心に感じはあります
大樹に浸っても 自分飼ってるゾウはもう単なるもうゾウを飼ってるぞという感じじゃなくて
すごい大事に大事に育てるんですよ
面倒を見てあげるは心配するは
なぜかというと このゾウさんのおかげで我々も食べているんだからということで
だからそこを生命馬鹿にしているわけじゃないんですね
もう互いの助けなければ生きていられないんだから
ですから この仏教での
このちっともこの生命の売買をやってはいけないと
武器売っては作ってはいけない
毒作ってはいけない 売ってはいけない
最初からそういう道徳を守ってしまったならば
世の中に問題ないのに
もう恐ろしい毒作ってるでしょ
兵器として みんな困らなくちゃいけない
僕 この化学兵器を作ってる人々がそれでひどい目に遭うならばありがたいんだけど
人類みんなひどい目に遭わなくちゃいけないんだから
だからそういうのは作る心理っていうのは
もう理解できないほど恐ろしいんです
なぜ作るんですかと 試しにでもなぜ作るんですか？人を殺すものでしょうに
相手を殺さなくちゃいけないと思うのは
こちらが臆病者でしょうに
そこで考えてるんですよ
ちゃんと教会に行って
もうあの なんとか食べて
あの懺悔すれば地獄天国に行くんだと
でも天国のところかもう二度と人間には戻らないだろうと思いますよ
もう直ちしかたいほど罪深いんです
私は人を殺せないんだとか思ってるかもしれませんけど
なんで機関銃を作ったんですか？なんで設計したんですか？なんでピストルとかね
そういうものを設計したんですか？作ったんですか？と
だから作る時でも恐ろしい概念がある
便利で使いやすくて持ち運べると
で それで人を殺せると
昔もあったでしょ？あの昔戦争で使ったこの鉄砲じゃない
何て言いますか あのでっかいこの車みたいなもので
ちょっと運んでどこかに置いていて
弾を入れて ぼーんとあのいろいろいろんなところで
今あの ああいうものだったらそんなに持ち運べないし
それ一つ持っていても身の安全に持っていくとかね
そうすると集団戦争の場合は
もう町を守るためにずっと周りにそういうものをセットして
ここからどうなんて撃つしかない方法なかったんだけど
それは不便だと そこでポケットの中にちゃんと持っていけるようなところまで小型化すると
で 弾は何発でも 30発でもずっともう撃てるようにと
またいろいろ工夫したりと
だからなんでああいうものは作るんで
作るんだから使うでしょうに
だから作らないためにはすごい精神的な強さ必要なんです
私はこの自分の組の子どもたちに昔はね
まあよく言ったんだけど
大体もう 18歳  19歳になっちゃうとね
まあ結構性格は荒っぽいし
たまにこういう何とか
まあ何て言いますか ナイフとか持ってるすごい体格悪い筋肉ついてる若者がいるんです
見るだけでもすごい怖そうな感じで
で まあ私にはそんなに怖い顔を見せませんだからね
よく話したりするし 話しちゃうと
まあその子供たちがもうそういう自分持ってるナイフとか見せたりするんですよ
見せたりすると 僕はあれ
お前よっぽど臆病者ですねとか言うんです
で これもすごい自信がある子供たちでしょうね
もう 4人でも平気でもうぶん殴れるぐらい体力もあるし
お前よっぽど臆病者だなと言ったら
もう何ですか？と言ったら
臆病者だからそんなもの持ってるよと
自分に自信がある人は何も持たないんだと
怖いものはないと思う人は何も持たない
だから僕らなんかは全く何も持ってないんだと
誰にも殴られたこともないんだと
それはかわいそうに と言ったって
もうああいう連中と付き合うんだから
もう殴られる可能性ありますよ
あの人もそういうナイフ持ってますよと
と言うんだけど いや 違いますと
お前が怖がってる お前は臆病者
だからそんなものを持ってるんだと
で そこでもう気づいてる子供は
そういうナイフなんかもうちゃんと捨てる
捨てて無意味のない生活に戻る
それですごく自信がついてくるし
誰にも殴ったりはしないし
ですから 最初からそういうものは作らなかったならば
世の中っていうのはもう究極の幸福な世界になるんでしょうね
だからこの戦況は知らなかったことであって
まあしょうがないと まあそういう 3つ
サンマーワーチャーサンマーカンマンとサンマーアーディーヨ
サンマーアーディーヨっていうのは仕事を正しい仕事をしなさいっていうこと
それでまあ時間は飛びました
アッパマンニャー 2つあります
無量心 無量心処 そちらには説明は省略します
無量心というのはもう限りなく広げて良い感情なんですね
だからどんな感情でももうあまり広げちゃ広げないんです
例えば怒り 怒りはどんどん膨張させようと思ったっても
これ以上できないというところがあるんです
車でもね まああの アクセラレーター押せば押すほど速く飛ぶでしょ？スピード出すでしょ
でもここまでというところがあるんですね
それ以上はいくらアクセルアクセラレーター踏んでもスピードは出ないと
で 怒りやらそういう感情の場合は
まあこれまでということはあります
怒りがどんどん出てくると
体の中はものすごい強烈に毒が生まれてくるんですね
毒が生まれてきて 心臓
腎臓 全部臓器がもうイカれてきて
自分がその場で死ぬんです
ですから それ以上は増えません
欲も同じく心臓発作を起こして死ぬところまで欲を膨張することができます
怒りも同じ 心臓発作も
すごく怒ったら で だからとことん成長させようと思っても不可能なんです
その前に人が死んじゃいますから
車と同じ いくらでもスピード出そうと思ったって出せないんです
車は道路から飛び出しちゃって
ひっくり返っちゃって
もう死んじゃうんです
コントロールできなくて
そうじゃなくて いくら広げても大丈夫
OK という感情が四ですね
慈悲喜捨 慈悲喜捨って
だから無量心というんです
四つがあるんです 四つあるんだけど
こちらは二つしか取ってない
カルナとムディタ かな
そう で なぜかというと
アドーサがありましたね
不信 怒りのない心相 怒りのない心相っていうのはメッターなんですね
慈悲のは慈しみなんです
同じ心相 同じ働き そこで中遮というなんとかありましたし
そういうのはウペッカーに
慈悲喜捨の捨に似てるんです
同じ働きですから別に扱ってない
ダブるんだからと 基本はもうあまり意味がないんだけど
結構ダブってますけど
お話 で このムディタっていうのはカルマ
カルマというのは心のすごく優しさというかね
他人の苦しみを見て 本当に何とかしてあげたくなる気持ちなんですね
偉くなるためでも何でもなくて
あんたは苦しんでるんだから助けてあげますと
それぐらいの それは当たり前に感じること
人を助けるのは当たり前だと
人の悩み 苦しみなくしてあげる
それはもうどうしたことないんだと
という気持ちで ですから
どんな人でも苦しんでほしくないと
という思う感情ですね
それすごい気持ちのいい感情なんですよ
で 試しに人を殺すことを人と喋ったりとかね
どうやればバレないように
もう完璧に殺人できますか？とか
完全犯罪 どうやればできるかどうか考えてみてください
どういうこと？気持ち悪くなるかというと
[笑い]であるいは日本が中国を攻めることか
韓国を攻めることとかね
もうあるいは日本の自衛隊が行って
もう沖縄ですか もう沖縄のアメリカの兵隊さんを追い出そうとかね
そういうことをもう別に冗談で考えてみてください
別に真面目でもなくてもいいんですから
それぐらいででもものすごい気持ち悪くなるはずなんです
考えると その代わりに平和のことをやら
みんな仲良くすることやらとか考える
気持ちいい ですから 人を助けてあげますと
どんな人でも苦しんでほしくないんだと
で 苦しむ人々になんとかできてあげ
してあげればいいなと
そういう方向で考えると
すごく自分が喜びを感じる
充実感感じる ですから
そういう感情はいくらでも広げます
なぜならば その感情が生まれるとどんどん元気になりますから
すごく元気になる 怒りを育てると元気じゃなくて
どんどん体が硬くなって
最終的には心臓発作を起こして確実に死ぬ
そして体がこう慈悲の感情
感情が生まれると 慈しむのではなくて
人の苦しみをなくしたいというカルナの感情が生まれてくると
体が楽しい 元気 健康的になる
心も健康的になる どんどんどんどん健康的になって
体はどんどん軽くなって
ものすごい体の存在を忘れるところまで軽くなるんです
ですから そういうのは無量心であると
どこまででも実践して成長しなさいということを言っているんです
カルナはカルナっていうのは苦しんでいる人々を助けてあげたくなる気持ち
人の苦しみをなくしたくなる気持ち
私たちは お釈迦様にはマハーカルナというんです
お釈迦様にあった感情はカルナであったんだと
慈悲ではなかったと 慈悲っていうのは一般的に慈しみに使っている言葉ですけど
別にみんなと仲良くしたいとか全く要らなかったんです
お釈迦様にとっては解脱してるんだから
でも自分が解脱して みんな大変苦しんでいるんですね
やっぱり何とかしなくちゃと
ただそれだけの気持ちだからカルナのみ
慈悲喜捨の悲 それだけ
ですからパーリ文献になると
お釈迦様のことはいつでもマハーカルナ
マハーカルナというマハーという偉大なるカルナで持っていたんだと
マハーマイトリと言わない
そうすると弥勒菩薩のことも言いたいんだけど
マイトリでは弥勒菩薩になってしまいますから
お釈迦様はカルナという言葉
で だいたい一つでいいんですからね
育てる場合は 残りはムディターですね
ムディターでも喜ぶということで
それも正真正銘の明るさなんですね
人々の幸福を見て 嫉妬の反対なんですね
ですから喜ぶ ああ よかったよかった
あの人にいい仕事を見つかってよかった
あの人に結婚できてよかった
子供が授けられて ああ
よかったと そういうふうに人の幸福を見てみて
ああ よかったよかったと自分楽しむ
何見たって それはだから噂言うことの反対
噂言うためには 人の悪いとこしか見てはいけないんですね
ですから 喜ぶ人は人のいいところしか見ないんです
いいとこ見る自分も楽しいんです
だから ゴミを探すか宝物を探すか
どっちかなんですよ 世の中のゴミを片っ端から探そうという人は
毎日ゴミしか見えないんですね
宝物を探そうと思う人には
毎日宝物しか見つからないんです
だから宝見つかって大喜びと
また探して また宝物見つかったら大喜びと
ゴミ探す人は臭いものを探す人はそういう臭い経験しか得られない
ですからカルナ ムディターっていうのは
そういう風にゴミ箱を探すんじゃなくて
宝物を探そうって感じで
世の中の生命持っているいいところ
それですごく素晴らしく生きていられる
その 2つはこの前の 19 のセットの中にないんだから
そこで別に書いているんです
そこでなんで別なカテゴリーになったかというと
解脱する心には慈悲喜捨はないんです
ヴィパッサナーすると別に働くんです
だから普通の仏教では慈悲
慈悲の瞑想もほどほどにやって
ヴィパッサナー瞑想もする
その 2つは合わないんです
合わない なぜならば 慈悲喜捨の瞑想はどうみんなと仲良く幸福で生きていられますか？という問題に答えてくれる
ヴィパッサナー瞑想はこの生きる智慧というものはどうやって乗り越えられるかと
ですから 全く正反対なんですね
みんな生命と一緒にどうやって生きていられるか
生命と関係なくどうやって逃げるかという 2つだから
ですから この二つを実践しながら生きなくなっちゃうんですよ
解脱というのはもう次元超えてる話だから
人間というのは生きている間は生きていなくちゃいけないんだから
慈悲は忘れるわけにはいきません
解脱体験する時まで 慈悲でないと生きていられないんですね
慈悲でないと我々は生かされてくれないんですね
生かされてくれなきゃ解脱できないんですね
だから慈悲は必要になる
解脱してもすぐ死にませんから
やっぱり慈悲喜捨は必要になっちゃう
その時は喜だけでいいんです
カルマだけ 私は大丈夫ですけど
あなたたちには助けてあげるということで
ですから この別なカテゴリに無量心所二つだよと
本当は四つですけど ここでは二つだよと別なカテゴリに入れてるんです
その二つは悟る心には生まれません
理由は悟る心にはこの生命のことを考えてないんです
無常のこと 苦のこと 無 myのこと考えてるんです
生命の苦しみなくしてあげようと思ったりすると
悟りの心じゃないんです
輪廻見ている心ですから
みんな幸福で生きているんだなと思って喜んじゃうと
また輪廻に執着している心ですから
悟る過程では入らないんです
そこはすごい丁寧に理解しなきゃ
もう大変邪見になりますよ
悟りにはそんなことは要りませんとか何とかと言っちゃったら
それは邪見であって すごい丁寧に解釈して理解しなくちゃいけない
じゃあ最後に残るのは一つ
たった一つの心所だけ
別に一つのカテゴリ 心所一つだけ
それはパンニャー 智慧
だから精神上簡単ですよ
十九種類が今日普遍的なもので
それから三つが戒律の世界の心所で
それは八正道にも入ります
大事なもの また二つは
まあ慈に対する二つと
一つは別に扱っているんです
大事な宝物と それはパンニャー
智慧 それも限りなく広げられるんです
パンニャーには特別な力があるんです
パンニャーっていうのは
ありのままものを見られるということ
パンニャーがなくてもサティはできますよ
普通みんなやってるのはそういうことなんです
ただサティの実践している
でも全然頭が冴えてこないと
パンニャーが生まれてこない
やってるのはやってるんだけどと
で パンニャーが生まれてきたら
そんなにやることなくなっちゃうんで
パンニャーはすごく力強くて
パンニャーこそこの核なんです
いわゆる まあ例えば原発がありますね
ものすごい大きな場所で
ものすごい建物使って頑張ってるでしょうに
でも一番基本って一番必要なところは原子炉なんです
それはそんな大きくないんです
あの揺れに ちょっとした棒でしょうに
あれはすごい細いんです
でも全部やってるのは全部あくまでもほんの細い揺れる棒なんです
それはあの鉛から外してあげたらもうすぐ燃え始めちゃう
強烈な熱を出してくれる
それで原発は自然に消える
活動する それはあれはもう核のエネルギーは悪い例なんですけど
そういうふうにいい方向にしたっても
パンニャーこそが機能してくれる真相なんです
それはありのままに見られるということ
判断なしに見られるということなんです
宗教的な定義になった方が分かりやすい
その場合は 無常であることを無我であること
すべては生滅変化しているんであって
実体がない 全部現象であると
それをきちんと体験して理解する
それによって執着は消える
煩悩はなくす 壊す 壊れる
その働きを持っています
煩悩を壊す能力あるのは智慧だけ
で我々もやっぱりタバコ吸ってはいかんとかね
酒飲んではいかんなとかわかってるんだけどやってしまうでしょうに
だから善悪判断がありますよ
怒ってはいけませんとか
みんな知ってるでしょうに
あ 嫉妬 あんなもの本当はよくない
よくないと ですから 道徳判断は知ってますけど
じゃあなんであんた嫉妬しますかと
なんであんた怒るんですか？なんでタバコ吸ってるんですかと
なんでアル中になってるんですか？というと
そこは智慧がないんですね
ですから 道徳判断があっても煩悩はなくせません
仏教を勉強しても心の煩悩は消えないんです
仏教を勉強していると智慧が生まれてくると
やっぱりこれはアカンという風な納得いけると
納得いったところでもうやれない状態に心変える
ですから パンニャーは全部活動
全部の世界で王様はパンニャーであって
司令官はパンニャーであって
中央制御なんとかというセンターコントロールユニットはパンニャーなんです
全部コントロールする
で 向こうの命令によってサッダーも信仰もサティも全部働いてくれる
でも家来はいくら働いたっても何の役にも立たん
上からちゃんと下命令がないと
あのシロアリとかね 一生懸命頑張っちゃいますけど
シロアリの女王様を捕まってみてください
あの 何万匹いるんでしょうかね
何十万匹とわからないほどたくさんいるでしょう
みんな死んじゃう 何のことなく
女王様というか 女王  蜂の場合でもね
ミツバチの場合でも 女王蜂バチが亡くなったらもうどうしようもないんです
でも実際にはミツバチが蜜を持ってくるわ
もう子供は育てるわ 巣を作るわ
みんなやってるのはその一人一人なんですけど
でも女王蜂が必要なんです
それが亡くなったら終わり
そういうふうに善心種はいっぱいあるんだけど
ちゃんと働いてくれますよ
この我々は堕落したり
また立ち直ったり また落ち込んだりとか
その波は消えません それしっかりともういい状態に保つためには
パンニャーという心種を作らなくちゃいけない
それはあくまでも独立したカテゴリーに入ってあって
パンニャーを育てるように気をつけるということは大事
必要なんです そのために仏教はあるんだと
そこで仏教は いうのは他のどんな宗教でもそこまではできますけど
仏教 パンニャーの心種の育て方は
この仏教のお釈迦様おっしゃっている真理でないとダメなんです
それもお釈迦様だけの真理ではなくて
苦であること 渇愛 苦集滅道ですか
渇愛から苦が生まれることと
で この中道的な生き方で智慧が現れてきて
渇愛はなくさなくちゃいけないという法則が必要なんです
神は作った 神は作ってないんだとか
そんな話ではパンニャーが生まれません
絶対的な神がいるんだ
絶対的な神がいないんだとか
そんなのはもうどうでもいいんです
八正道を実践して苦集滅道を理解することによってパンニャーが生まれる
それで今現には仏教でしかその話はないんだから
まあしょうがない でも他のどんな宗教にしたって宗教なくても
このパンニャー以外の善心種は生まれるんです
パンニャーもまあちょびちょびと生まれるんですけどね
そんなにこのすごいすごい力では生まれません
まあ善心種は以上です
じゃあ終わりましょう
うん すごい時間かかりました今日は
じゃあどうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました